verán todo tipo de criaturas.
Pero si vemos hace 2000 años,
verán estos cuatro mamíferos:
cerdos, vacas, ovejas y cabras.
Es igual en el caso de las aves.
Al ver en los menús de restaurantes de Nueva York
de hace 150- 200 años,
verán escolopácidos, becadas, urogallos, docenas de patos y gansos.
Pero al ver la cría de animales moderna,
verán cuatro:
pavos, patos, pollos y gansos.
Es lógico que nos hayamos dirigido en esa dirección.
Pero ¿cómo nos hemos dirigido en esta dirección?
Bien..
primero es un problema muy, muy nuevo.
Es la forma cómo hemos estado pescando en los océanos en los últimos 50 años.
Con la Segunda Guerra Mundial declaramos la guerra contra los peces.
Toda la tecnología perfeccionada durante la Segunda Guerra Mundial,
sonares, polímeros ligeros,
todas se redirigieron a los peces.
Y este tremendo incremento de la capacidad pesquera,
se cuadruplicó con el transcurso del tiempo,
desde el final de la Segunda Guerra Mundial hasta nuestros días.
Eso significa que
extraemos entre 80 y 90 millones de toneladas métricas del mar cada año.
Eso es el equivalente al peso humano de China
que se saca del mar cada año.
Y no es casualidad que use a China como ejemplo
porque China es ahora el mayor país pesquero del mundo.
Bueno, eso es solo la mitad de la historia.
La otra mitad de la historia
es este increíble auge de la piscicultura y la acuicultura,
que ahora, solo en el último año o dos,
empezó a superar la cantidad de peces salvajes que extraemos.
Así que si se suman los peces salvajes y los cultivados,
se obtiene el equivalente a dos Chinas del océano
cada año.
Y de nuevo, no es una coincidencia que use a China como el ejemplo,
porque China, además de ser el mayor pescador
también es el mayor acuicultor.
Veamos las cuatro opciones que tenemos en este momento.
La primera,
y por mucho el marisco más consumido en EE. UU. y gran parte de Occidente,
es el camarón.
El camarón de la naturaleza, como un producto natural,
es un producto terrible.
Se matan 10, 20, 30 kilos de peces salvajes regularmente
para llevar medio kg. de camarón al mercado.
También es muy ineficiente llevarlo al mercado en términos de combustible.
En un estudio reciente de la Universidad de Dalhousie,
se encontró que la pesca del camarón
es una de las formas más intensivas de emisión de carbono.
Así que se pueden cultivar,
y la gente los cultiva,
y cultivan mucho en esta misma zona.
El problema es
el lugar donde están las granjas del camarón son estos hábitats silvestres:
los bosques de manglar.
Vean esas raíces encantadoras bajando.
Las mantienen en el suelo, protegen las costas,
crean hábitats para todo tipo de peces y camarones jóvenes,
y son importantes para este entorno.
Bueno, esto es lo que ocurre con muchos de los manglares costeros.
Hemos perdido millones de acres de manglares costeros
en los últimos 30 o 40 años.
Esta tasa de destrucción se ha ralentizado,
pero todavía tenemos un déficit importante de manglares.
Lo otro que está pasando aquí
es un fenómeno que el cineasta Marcos Benjamin llama "Moliendo a Nemo".
Este fenómeno es muy, muy relevante
para todo lo que se ve en un arrecife tropical.
Porque lo que está pasando en este momento,
es que tenemos camaroneros arrastrando con el camarón,
una gran cantidad de captura incidental,
que su vez, se muele y se convierte en alimento del camarón.
Y a veces, muchas de estas embarcaciones,
tripuladas por esclavos,
capturan los llamados "peces basura"
peces que nos encantaría ver en un arrecife,
y los muelen
y los convierten en alimento para camarones,
un ecosistema que literalmente se come a sí mismo y escupe camarón.
El segundo pescado más consumido en EE. UU.
y también en todo Occidente,
es el atún.
Así que el atún es el pez mundial definitivo.
Estas áreas de gestión enormes se deben vigilar
a fin de que el atún esté bien administrado.
Nuestra propia área de gestión,
llamado la Organización Regional de Ordenación Pesquera,
se llama la CICAA,
la Comisión Internacional para la Conservación del Atún Atlántico.
El gran naturalista Carl Safina la llamó una vez,
"La conspiración internacional para pescar todos los atunes."
Por supuesto hemo visto mejoras increíbles
en la CICAA en los últimos años,
hay mucho espacio para la mejora,
pero queda por decir que el atún es un pescado mundial,
y para su gestión, tenemos que manejar el mundo.
Bueno, también podríamos tratar de criar atún
pero el atún es muy malo para la acuicultura.
Muchas personas no saben esto, pero el atún es de sangre caliente.
Pueden calentar sus cuerpos 20° por encima de la temperatura ambiente,
pueden nadar a más de 60 km/hr.
Así que eso prácticamente elimina
todas las ventajas de la agricultura de peces
Un pescado de piscifactoría es
o un pez es de sangre fría, o uno que no se mueve mucho.
Eso es bueno para el cultivo de proteínas.
Pero si hay una criatura salvaje y loca
que nada a 60 km/hr. con sangre caliente,
no es un buen candidato para la acuicultura.
La siguiente criatura,
más consumida en EE. UU. y en todo el Occidente
es el salmón.
También saqueamos el salmón,
pero en realidad no necesariamente por la pesca.
Este es mi estado natal de Connecticut.
Connecticut solía ser el hogar de una gran cantidad de salmón salvaje.
Pero si vemos este mapa de Connecticut,
cada punto en este mapa es una presa.
Hay más de 3000 presas en el estado de Connecticut.
Creo que esta es la razón por la que la gente en Connecticut es muy tensa,
(Risas)
Si alguien simplemente desbloqueara el chi de Connecticut,
creo que podríamos tener un mundo infinitamente mejor.
Hice este comentario particular,
en una convención de oficiales de parques nacionales,
y un tipo de Carolina del Norte se me acercó y me dijo,
"Sabes, no deberías ser tan duro con Connecticut,
porque nosotros aquí en Carolina del Norte, tenemos 35 000 represas".
Es una epidemia nacional e internacional.
Hay presas en todas partes,
y precisamente
evitan que el salmón salvaje llegue a sus lugares de desove.
Así que, como resultado, hemos usado la acuicultura
y el salmón es uno de los más exitosos, al menos en los números.
Cuando empezó el cultivo del salmón,
podía tomar hasta 3 kg. de peces silvestres
para hacer solo medio kg. de salmón.
La industria ha mejorado mucho.
Han llegado por debajo de dos a uno,
aunque es un poco engañoso
porque si nos fijamos en la manera en que se produce la acuicultura,
se está midiendo en gránulos,
kilos de gránulos por kilo de salmón.
Estos gránulos son a su vez pescado.
Así que en realidad, el pescado que entra y el que sale,
es algo difícil de calcular.
Pero en cualquier caso,
hay que darle crédito a la industria,
se ha reducido la cantidad de pescado por kg. de salmón.
El problema es que aumentamos
la cantidad de salmones que estamos produciendo.
La acuicultura es el sistema alimentario de más rápido crecimiento en el mundo.
Crece algo así como 7 % por año.
Y así, a pesar de que requerimos menos por pez
para ponerlos en el mercado,
aún estamos matando a una gran cantidad de peces pequeños.
Y no solo estamos alimentando a los peces con peces,
también estamos alimentando pollos y cerdos con peces.
Así que tenemos pollos que comen pescado,
pero extrañamente, también tenemos peces que comen pollo.
Los productos derivados de los pollos como las plumas, sangre, huesos
se muelen y alimenta a los peces.
Así que me pregunto a menudo,
¿es un pez que se comió un pollo que se comió un pez?
Es como una reelaboración del huevo y la gallina. Como sea.
(Risas)
En conjunto, sin embargo, resulta un problema terrible.
Estamos hablando
es algo de entre 20 y 30 millones de toneladas métricas de criaturas salvajes